taliban declared china their closest
ally this is a telegraph story china is
the taliban's principal
partner in the international community
the islamist group has said it is its
strongest signal yet of diplomatic
priorities taliban spokesman zabiola
mujahid on thursday claimed beijing was
ready to invest and reconstruct
afghanistan as he set out hopes that
china would provide a gateway to global
markets mr mujad said that the chinese
would revive afghan copper mining and
production as the express admiration for
the one belt uh one road project under
which china extends significant lows to
the other countries to invest in
infrastructure western critics have
framed the initiative as a debt trap
that helped chinese extend
uh geopolitical influence a charge
rejected by chinese leaders david i'm
going to go to you first with this one
so
the taliban wants a seat at the table
they want to see it at the g7
they want to be recognized as a world
leader
on my podcast over the last couple of
weeks i've had a very close friend of
mine victor marks
um who's been
to afghanistan he's got a house still in
iraq uh he's a former marine uh he's a
veteran his his co is a delta guy jeff
teagues
and he's got assets on the ground that
whole pineapple express that we heard
about where the veterans went in and
actually rescued thousands doing doing
more for americans that than this by the
administration was doing kennedy tim
what up
so
victor's team is a part of that
coalition that tim kennedy is a part of
chad uh uh
pineapple explo apple express yeah so he
shared with me because right before we
pulled out right before biden pulled out
i'd say wouldn't say weeks i don't think
most americans don't believe that we
should have left the way that we did the
withdrawal shouldn't happen the way that
it did and americans are still left
behind i was worried that we were going
to start to see some of these you know
just straight up executions you know
throats getting slit taliban's just you
know that's what they're gonna do
and victor helped bring me down and gave
me a lot of peace to just think about
he's like they're looking at the
long-term play here the taliban's
looking at now they've got control of
afghanistan there's three trillion
dollars in minerals in the soil in
afghanistan and they want a seat at the
table they want to be recognized as a
world leader they want to they want to
have a say-so at the g7
so china coming in
giving them the the being becoming a
partner with them giving them the rights
to be able to go in mine
it's going to help them of course
absolutely diplomatically and they're
sitting on a gold mine of americans they
they want to ransom these americans they
want to sell them back to us basically
they want they want to get paid so i
don't think we're going to see slaughter
i think we're going to see what we're
already hearing some of the reports that
taliban's not letting americans leave
they want they want ransom payments made
and here we've got china that is just
continuing to you know make their their
marks bigger and stronger with more
connections and here we've got the
little united states of america with joe
biden at the helm
not a real leader and somebody that's
afraid to tell the taliban what we
should do and what we will do instead
he's taking orders okay we'll be out by
the 31st you know okay we'll do this and
that it's just it's an absolute mess but
the taliban is is
yeah and china connecting is absolutely
something that we that the world should
be very very concerned about
i think um
what this does is kind of come down to
alignment everything's kind of falling
into place based on who your homies are
all right it's like what am i getting at
what's the correlation between china and
the taliban because that's not exactly
like they've been
in cahoots the common denominator is
pakistan china has been influencing
pakistan they've invested in pakistan
pakistan clearly has been in cahoots
with the taliban al qaeda all all that
fun stuff
who has the united states been you know
in alignment with india so india is the
regional power over there india
and pakistan have major beef it's kind
of
it's kind of like you know the the axis
and the axis of evil and the allies kind
of all taking place so
it's kind of like draft picks if you
ever play five on five all right i got
this guy all right i got this guy united
states drafted
uh india china drafted pakistan pakistan
comes with a taliban we've got certain
this country over here and that's
essentially what's taking place here it
is concerning that the
taliban is aligning with china best
friends of china are you surprised
i'm not because again they're aligned
with pakistan that's why i'm not
surprised yeah no i i the china is going
to align with anybody who hates america
yep yep what do you what are you talking
about like the phone call you got to
make is uh can we make a list of
countries that hate america who's at the
top china okay make a phone call right
exactly we'll take iran we'll take north
korea we'll take russia that's on our
team whereas the united states will take
india we'll take israel we'll take the
united kingdom anyone that hates anyone
that hates democracy and that's what i'm
saying when they hate our democracy
well look at the one built one road
project i mean that's so freaking huge
yeah you know shout out to uh general
robert spalding for a stealth war book
guys i've been talking about these books
ever since it came out you guys need to
start reading it i mean basically let
out you know he just laid out the
freaking playbook i mean and it's and
it's very unfortunate that it actually
is playing out because
you know you got you got americans
literally on social media
liking certain communism you know
feeds and they have no freaking clue
what's happening right now and what's
going to happen as
china alliance aligns themselves with
people like the taliban i mean this is
this is very dangerous this is not for
play i'm going to keep saying this i'm
going to keep saying this uh because
i think there's china's number one enemy
today
that they fear china has learned they
can control america yeah easy they're
already here yeah they have figured out
a formula because the the challenge with
a lot of people in america politicians
that can be bought money all this stuff
it's very easy to buy america today
china's got the formula they're killing
it more power to them on their strategy
they're obviously enemy but all i'm
saying is yeah they outsmarted american
politics right but there's one country
they despise there's only one country
they despise i pulled up data the other
day we're looking at ages
do you know the average age
of population in u.s what is the average
age we have 330 million give or take
people living in the u.s guess what's
the average age of an american today 40
45 80 40 i'm sorry average you say 42
you're pretty close what do you think it
is i was thinking mid-40s okay 38.1 okay
millennials are the largest generation
baby boomers before that 38 points what
do you think is the average age of a ch
uh uh uh citizen in china lower than
that what do you think it is no i would
say higher higher 38.4 okay by the way
not that far 38.1 38.4 what do you think
is the average age of someone in india
in their late 20s
what do you think no idea 26 years old
yeah wow 26 to 38. look india
won't do it whoever is the next
president that needs to do this if i'm
us
if i want to protect
the world long term to make sure a china
doesn't i'm doing whatever i can to
strengthen india with our relationship
anything i can to do to strengthen them
that's where i'm going because the same
game these guys are playing you got to
go to the one person they fear the most
it's like that one person a guy doesn't
want his you know the the family to talk
to or girl to talk to or you know a
person to find out about who's that one
person china fears if india gets
stronger right i'm going to do whatever
i can to strengthen india today because
china is going to shiver if india gets
stronger because china is getting older
that whole one baby rule backfired on
them okay that one baby roll is what got
the average should be 38.4 and fyi
america's not as young as we're acting
like we are we're only 38.1 it's like
china and us is about the same age india
is 26. so there is a there is a savior
there for the world and it's india so
you want to you want wanna team up with
taliban no problem china you go team up
with taliban hey here's what we're gonna
do you got 75 000 taliban people you
just teamed up with good for you china
we just teamed up with one and a half
billion right let me tell you what we're
going to be doing we're going to
strengthen them let's create a
partnership and go tell the world about
it that's what i would be doing but
they're a democracy let's not forget
democracy or democracy and
dictatorship's alignment they are
brilliant they are great engineers
they're willing to work they are hungry
for information they want to learn they
have their own bollywood they have
they're creative they have so many
different benefits there's so much to
build out there they're passionate
people super passionate people they got
a rich history as well there's some
areas with mindset that can be improved
but they got strong school iit is one
the best engineering school in the world
some will say it's even better than mit
in the u.s so anyways i think china
fears india i agree so i agree my whole
talk about alignment and i give the
analogy of the draft picks if you have
the two great powers these days
united states and china and we have our
first pick
we're taking india yeah if it's taliban
china just picked up a scrappy player
you know you're building a basketball
team they just picked up a scrappy
player yeah but you know who india is
india is a guy you can build a team the
first round draft pick not only a first
round driver he is a shack this is a
individual
this is a franchise
player dynasty is like a
patrick
beverly's too good dude
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye
[Music]